Good morning, Vrinda.
Good morning, sir.
Good morning.
Good morning,
Rakesh.
Bhavani.Good
morning, sir. Good morning. Good morning, Lishman. Good morning, sir. Good morning.
Good morning, Vincent.
So good morning
all.
Good morning, sir.
Good morning. Good morning. Devesh.
You
can
start it now, sir. I mean,
yes.
27:28. So I'll present the screen, sir.
And... Yeah, please, please. Okay.
So here you would like to
speak anything then I will take on today mostly the hands-on
part. So
can you just roll the slides previous slide?
Yes, yeah it is. Just let us. It is
great though. Yeah.
Yeah we can go a few slides earlier. Earlier, yes.
We can have a quick recap I will do.
Next slide. So good
morning all. I think we can start. I am
assuming all of you are thinking no it is
going deeper and deeper.
So somehow you have to spend time on learning the videos and
practice session what sir demonstrates on the PyTorch.
That is the only way. But once you
know
start
in that way it's not any deep math or something.
Once you start
following the video lecture and parallelly practice the
PyTorch that will help you. That is a
good way to get into that. So if
you quickly recall you have
a two layer network means feed forward two layer network means one input layer
is linear units
and the perceptron one perceptron layer is there.
In the perceptron layer you can deal with linearly
separable classes that we discussed long back.
Whereas there are representation problems
hard problem hard problems which are if the classes are not
linearly separable then single layer perceptron
is not sufficient. That is why people went for two layer and three layer
perceptrons. With three layer perceptrons and
one input layer a four layer network will be able to do
any type of machine learning task.
So that is the
conceptual framework they proposed.
But it resulted in a next challenge in
the feed forward neural network
theory. What is called
the hard learning challenge.
Now
they have a framework
for dealing with any
complex machine learning tasks. However they do not
know how to train that framework or train that multi-layer
perceptron.And it
nearly stalled the field for a decade or so.
So after that, you know, the, uh, some
researchers proposed what is called, um, backpropagation
learning algorithm
and that is what, uh, sir is going to explain last time, but he will
now tell about the, um,
how to put it onto the PyTorch and explain
that. Um, just as a quick
recall,
um, uh, uh,
any feedforward network when we take and, uh, consider
to use it for a machine learning task in a supervised
way, we have input data given, corresponding output, uh,
data is given. Means input-output patterns are given.
Then as per the perceptron learning, if I know the output,
uh, target output, then the actual output comes out of the perceptron,
then take the error between the two and use that error to adjust the
weights. That's what the perceptron learning .
But now if you see in this figure, now I have a three-layer network where two are
perceptron, one is the input is a linear layer.
So in this ta- in this case, for the output layer, which are named as
one, two, et cetera, capital K, for that we know the target
output. Since we know the target output and we know the input
applied in the input layer, once I know the target output, I know the
actual output, then get the error
and then to adjust weights leading to this out- the output, uh, perceptron
layer. Whereas the hidden perceptron layer, we do not know the target
output. Since I do not know the target
output, uh, I cannot compute the error between
the, uh, target output and the actual output,
and hence they are called as hidden layers because we don't have access to the
target output of that layer. If I do not know the
error, I will not be able to adjust the weights leading to the
links to the hidden layer. That is WK,
WIJH which is shown in the figure. Those
weights I cannot adjust and that was called hard learning
problem, hard learning problem. The differentiation between
hard
problem or representation problem versus hard learning problem is now I
will not be able to adjust the weights of the links
leading to the hidden layers, okay?
And that resulted in stalling of the neural network field for over a
decade, okay? So then
the, the co- ultimately the breakthrough came from the backpropagation
learning algorithm is, see whether I have
a target output or not in the hidden layer.
Somehow if you, if I know the error here at the output
of the hidden layer, that is all. See, why do I need target output?
If I know the target output, I can s- subtract the actual output
from the target output to get the error and use that error to adjust the
weights of the links leading to the hidden layer.
Now, since I don't have the target output, if
somehow I have a mechanism to get an estimate of the
error at the output of the hidden layer, then I can
adjust the weights of the links leading to the hidden layer.
That is the,
the idea they came up with for backpropagation learning
algorithm. So then how do I get the error for the output of the hidden
layer? I can come up with that er- error because
if you can suppose neuron 1 in the hidden layer,
the output of neuron 1 in the hidden layer it feeds all
the neurons in the, uh, output layer.
That means to say
it contributes to the fraction of the error in the output
layer, okay? Similarly, small J
neuron if I consider, it also contributes its
fraction of error to the total error in the output neuron.
Similarly, capital J output will constitute fraction of
error in the all the neurons in the net.
So, so accordingly, suppose I have errors from one et cetera
small K up to capital K
and that error since a fraction is contributed by neuron
one, I can get an estimate of the error at the
neuron one
from the errors at the output
layer. But how do I do that? I have
to pass on back that is why it is called a backpropagation, e-
error backpropagation algorithm. I propagate back the error.
How do I propagate back the error? If I have a step function like
that for perceptron, then it will be difficult because I don't have
a differential. I need a differential output function.
This error should be made proportional to the differential of the output error
and that is how the, uh, the discrete perceptron learning law is changed
into continuous perceptron learning law where the output function becomes
continuous. Accordingly, I have the slope or differential
value available at all instants of time or all
instants of, uh, X. Once I have
that, use that knowledge to adjust the, you know, estimate the errors at the
each of the, uh, neurons in the hidden layer and use them to
adjust the weights. So this is the big picture.
Even though when sir is explaining it because that is how the, the complexity is
there if you, uh know,
kindly, uh, appreciate that, uh,
concept, that simple framework and then we can proceed further.
Next slide, uh, Sunil.
Ah, that is how, you know, earlier step function which was there
as a perceptron when they basically proposed, they replaced it with a, a
non-linear... Function should be non-linear. Step function is also non-linear.
That's why they were using it. But now it is not, uh, differentiable
because difference is zero.We need a differential output function, that's why they
came up with sigmoidal function, dividing either by the logistic or by the
... The nature of the output function is like this.
When you take the differential, you have a non-zero differential output function
like this. And as a result of that, if I use
such a nonlinear output function as output functions in the
perceptron, I can pass on the error to the
previous layers. Otherwise, it's sealed off, okay?
So that is the basic idea they did. Next slide.
So, I think that's what they explained this hard learning problem.
Um, so, um, desired output only
for units in the output layer and not for units in the hidden layer.
So, that is where, you know, a learning rule, uh, that depends
on the difference between the desired output and the actual output is not feasible
here. So problem of upgrading weights is called the hard learning
problem. That's what I explained. Next slide.
So this hard l- hard learning problem, as I told, is solved by using the
differential nonlinear output function like sigmoidal.
Of course, now there are many, any nonlinear function you can take now.
We use ReLu function. Uh, any other nonlinear function we can use,
okay? So the corresponding learning law is called as, uh, is
based on propagating the error from the output layer to the hidden layer,
okay? So, and, uh, you know,
e- e- earlier, in the, uh, single layer perceptron or
two-layer network where input layer is neuron, the
learning law we were using was perceptual learning law or discrete
perceptual learning law, uh, or delta,
um,
uh, rule, they used to call it. But now,
this error correction is also extended to the
hidden layer. Mm. That's why the
name generalized delta rule came into picture.
Next slide.
Um, so, what we are m- now you are making
is, the change in the weight in any neuron is
made proportional to the error.
Uh, M is the, I think Mth iteration or something,
uh, total error. This error is at the output layer.
The error is at the output layer, so, um, there is a
proof, uh, mathematical proof if we see that,
um, the error at any point can be
related to the error in the output layer
because you see the connections going so you can relate to that.
So as a result of that, even though I'm talking, I need the error at the hidden
layer, that in turn can be expressed as a error in the output
layer and that is how then once I have the change in the weight, then you
can use that adjusting the weights. Next slide.
That's why this, this, uh, uh, ek- uh, slide I told that
figure, uh, uh, which I have shown initially. Next slide.
Uh, so oh, I just wanted to leave this, uh,
one. See, in the discrete case, data Wi is proportional
to only target output minus the actual output.
There is no differential output function here.
Signum is a step function. You follow only the first, uh, row what I
have put. Go to the next slide.
If you see in the first, uh, row, uh, we replaced the signum
with f. That means to say, f can be any nonlinear
function. Only condition is it has to be
differentiable. When it has to be differentiable, then
I multiply by differentiable factor.
Um, so accordingly, now the change in the weight is
proportional to the differential of the, um, um,
output error, the differential of the output error, okay?
So that is how this, this equation has been put and
using that, uh, you know, this, you can see, you know, the change in the error is b
minus error multiplied by the differential of the output
function. So accordingly, um, you
know, I can, with the help of this, I can back propagate the errors
into, uh, the earlier layers. Next slide.
I think this is where I think sir was explaining how the back propagation.
I know, uh, maybe you see, becomes too much when we are taking, uh, this one,
but I, I, s- I request all of you to go through that video
once again what sir explained last time and, uh, then we can proceed
further. Uh, Sunil, please.
Yes, sir. Thank you, sir. Thank you.
Okay. So, um, quickly, uh, even
I'll take you through the slides which we have covered in the last class and
then we may discuss it
for some of the queries if you have and then I'll take you to the
hands-on where, uh, demo, where I'll show you that how
exactly we can implement this forward propagation and backward
propagation. (sneezes)
And I have planned to, uh, show you two versions of
it. In the first version, we will see the forward
propagation and backward propagation, uh, completely in the PyTorch,
uh, uh, uh, the, wi- without using any, uh,
PyTorch modules, but, uh, in the second version, I'll
show you the backward, for the backward propagation, uh, there is one
module and that module, uh, called a, a
Autograd. So, um,
what it does, it takes cares of whatever, uh, whatever
back propagation you have to do, in the sense that whatever gradients we have
to calculate, it, it is, it, it is take, uh, it takes cares of my, it takes
care by the Autograd, PyTor- PyTorch module.
That is what we are going to see today, so.
And then we'll see that, okay, what is the difference whether we are getting the
same output from the PyTorch Autograd
or what we are writing from the scratch, what is the similarity and
so on.Okay. So I guess this figure is
clear to all of you and there is no, uh, query
that, okay, what happens when we forward propagate,
then we get a loss based on the, um,
means... Any loss function based on whatever kind of, uh,
problem statement you have, whether it is a, um, a...
If you are predicting a value then maybe mean squared error, squared error
will be your loss function. If it is a class type of output, then
maybe cross entropy would be the loss function. So you...
This loss function you can decide, you will get the loss and then you try to
minimize the loss with the number of iterations, and
you use the back propagation algorithm for that where you try to,
uh, you, uh, you try to, uh, you can say that update
these, these, uh, parameters while you...
In every iteration and see that, okay, how, how much reduction you have done
in the loss and so on. This process goes on. So this...
I guess this, uh, uh, forward propagation, backward propagation is
clear.
Okay, so I'll just quickly recap all those slide which we have
already seen. Uh, we are trying to, uh, spend little more time on
this back propagation and forward propagation because this is
the fundamentals for any kind of neural network or deep
learning, uh, deep learning neural network, whatever we are going to see next.
Everywhere, this is the same fundamentals is going to come, so
having good hold on the concept about the back propagation,
forward and... So that is very important, so we are trying to
emphasize on this particular part little, little
more. So yeah, this is the network,
what we built, okay? And we worked with only one
row of data, if you can recall. I have not shown you for
69, 75 and other three rows, but that will also
happen in the same way. And, uh, this was the network which we
de- designed, and in this particular network, what we did,
first we calculated the H1 value. So from before H1, we
calculated Z1 and Z1 was
W11X1W12X2 plus
B1, and once you're getting the ZU- Z1, you, uh, we
passed it through the nonlinear activation function that is ReLu
and ReLu has, uh, given us H1. Okay?
Similarly, it is true for H2 also, you see these, uh,
equations, you'll understand. So
W11X1W12X2B1 is your Z1.
Z1 you pass through the activation function ReLu, you get the
H1, similarly you get the H2. Then once H1, H2
you have, these acts as an input for the next layer neuron and next
layer you have only one neuron, which is also the output neuron in this
particular case. And here, Y... How do you calculate
Y, Y, Y hat? That would be
V1H1V2H2V3. This is how you calculate it.
Now, this was, I guess, clear to everyone.
So forward propagation was fine. Once we calculate the Y
ha- Y hat, then we compare it with the actual
output. The actual what output was supposed to be 3,
but what we are getting from this network was
10.36, so we calculated the loss, the squared error
loss, which came as 54.17. We said that we can
repeat it for all the data points. In that case, we calculate the
mean squared error, right? Here also you can calculate, but
the, the denominator would be one, so it will result in the same
value. So this is the loss what we got when
we started our
training of this particular neural network, and then
we saw the one iteration. In the sense,
we then, uh, changed all these parameters
using this update rule, okay? And then again, one more
time we did the forward propagation, calculated the loss and compared it with the
previous loss. This much we did. Now, if we talk about the back
propagation, this is the update rule which we have,
uh, which we have evaluated and
these update rule requires the gradient. This is the ma- uh, the...
This is the part which took little more time to understand as well as
to calculate. And what we are trying to do here is, the idea
is that whatever loss you are getting at the output layer, okay?
So that loss you want to minimize, and
the, the, the concept is we, we, we think,
uh, we, we think that, uh, this, this loss is
coming because we have not initialized or not,
um, maybe, uh, assigned the
optimum value for all these parameters.
Now, what is the optimum value for these parameters?
Like all these weights and biases that we don't know and that is what we are trying
to do with the help of back propagation.
So what we do, we say that,
uh, this loss is coming because of these
parameters, so hence let us update these parameters a little bit
with, with this update rule. And for that one, we have to calculate the
partial derivative of loss with respect to, with respect
to each of these parameters, okay?
And that is what we calculated, the three, uh, gradients or partial
derivative here and three for this H1 and three for this
H2 to total nine parameters, uh, uh, we need
to update and hence nine ingredients we require, and that is what we did
also. So only thing what we had to understand here is
that, okay, how do we, uh, uh, how do we
write the partial derivative chain rule? That is...
Uh, that was little bit of, um, a trickier part, but I guess with this,
uh, animations and with these figures, hopefully you must have
understood that in a better, better way.
That my loss depends on the prediction Y hat.
Y hat depends on each of these parameters, fine?
So we are going to calculate the partial derivative of loss with respect to Y hat,
which you can see here, which will come 2 into Y hat minus Y,
and then we'll calculate the partial derivative of Y hat with respect to each of
the... With respect to each of these parameter.
So we started with V1.... right? And then it came as
2 into Y hat minus Y into H1. Okay? Then we
did for V2, partial derivative of loss with respect to V2, which is
nothing but partial derivative of loss with respect to Y hat and Y hat with
respect to V2. Similarly, for B3. So, you see that
only the last, uh, first, first part is same because we
are calculate... We are going through Y hat.
And second part is changing here, okay? So this is the chain rule.
Then we did it for H1. Here, H1, a- again, with the H1, three
parameters are connected. so how do we, uh, calculate the partial
derivative of loss with respect to each of these?
We first will calculate partial derivative of loss with respect to Y
hat,
partial derivative of Y hat with respect to H1, and, uh,
partial derivative of H1 with respect to Z1, where we, you have, uh, you have
a function
called ReLu, okay? And then partial derivative of Z1 with respect to
W11 and one by one each of these parameters.
X1, X2 we don't, uh, don't want so we'll not do any
(clears throat) gradient calculation with respect to X1, X2 because these are my
inputs. So this is what is written here, the chain rule, okay?
So this flow you need to understand and then this will not look
complicated, okay? We did it for W12 then
B1 and we repeated for the H2 node also,
fine? So with respect to W21 then W22 and then
B2. All these things we calculated, hand-coded them,
and, uh, uh, calculated by hand. Right, so this was just a
recap for the forward propagation and then we actually substituted
those all values to get the gradient value and hence we
got
97.152. The gradient, when we calculated with
respect to V1, with respect to V2, it were
26.496. With respect to B3, it was
14.72 and then we calculated others also
(clears throat) . And finally, the, uh, all these nine
gradients which we are supposed to have to update all these nine
parameters, we calculated first.
Then, we started updating these parameters.
All right and, um, just substituted these values and get those
parameter. The learning rate here, we, uh,
uh, taken as 10 to the power minus 4.
Uh, the reason was that, uh, my, um,
uh... Because these gradients were very high.
You see that gradients is too, too high.
So if we don't take very small number like
0.0004 then this part where we are
multiplying the pi-... uh, like, eta, that is learning rate with the
gradient, eh, if, if the, one of the value is
not... So at least here, the gradient is very high, that means the eta has to be
small. Then only we can see the, uh, the, uh, the
resultant value will be small. Otherwise, what will happen, uh, the, this,
this value will be, uh, this value will go even bigger.
For, just for example, if the gradient is, uh, sorry,
if the learning rate is more than one,
which I consider as a bigger value, say that 2, then 2 into
97 will come, isn't it? So likewise.
So this is, this is one problem in the neural network which we'll talk in the next
class, that this, it is very important, it is very
important to keep this gradient, which is, uh,
partial derivative of loss with respect to whatever parameter you are
doing. Eh, it is very important to keep this gradient value, uh,
in a, in a, uh, uh, uh, in a, in a range such
that it should not be very high also and it should not be very low
also. I mean, it should not be very large number also, w- and, or small number
also. But here, we, we are seeing the case of where it is
being very, very large number. Like 97 is very large number, 26 is very
large. Similarly, 1413 is even larger number, right?
So we don't want our gradi- gradient to be, uh, such a large number.
Otherwise, it, it leads to a per- problem while training the
neural network, okay? And that problem is, is
known as exploding gradient problem, which will, which we'll see that in the
next class when I'll talk about the two different problem which happens,
uh, which, which, which occurs while training the neural network.
That is called vanishing gradient problem or exploding gradient problem,
okay? So, but here, this is the case.
This is how we have, uh, taken all those values.
So this is what we are getting, and hence purpose, purposely, I have taken this
learning rate very small so that I'll keep this, this particular component
smaller.
And then I substituted all these value, got all these parameters,
right? And then just re-, uh, iterated, means,
uh, recalculated the forward pass again for the new parameters.
These are all the new parameters value.
Recalculated the, um, new Y hat, which is
0.99 and calculated the new loss which is
4.005 in this particular case. And then we
compared these two, that how this old, old value and
new value and h- what is the change we are getting.
And hence, we saw a significant change from the,
uh, in, in, in terms of the loss. And that is what it is, uh, we wanted also.
So this was just a recap. Now, before I'll go into
the PyTorch to the Co- Colab, if you have any queries so
far understanding this back prop- back propagation or
anything, you can ask us first.
Any query from anyone?
Mm-hmm. Yes, sir. Good morning, sir. Rakesh, here, sir.
So main this change, it is decreasing due to the
factor learning rate we have provided is small, sir.
Right.
So from 10.36 to it is coming to
0.99. So learning rate is playing the major part
here actually, what I think so.
Uh, obviously, learning, uh, rate, uh, learning,
um, this eta parameter also we have chosen smartly here.
But, uh, the point is the focus is not on this, okay?
The focus is on these parameters which we have updated, okay?
And this is going to be the, the......
uh, uh, main focus when we do the back propagation rather than
this- obviously learning rate also has a significant say in order
to how, how your rates are changing and how the, how
the... Means, uh, the learning is happening for that neural network, no
doubt. But these are the main parameters, the weights and
biases, which is actually
impacting that, okay, what is going to be the next, uh,
Y hat or what will be the next loss value. Okay?
Yes.
Because going further you will see that this learning rate would be something
which you will not change much. It is something like people have, uh, tried
it for 0.01 and you would not be changing this much.
And, uh, going further, you will also see that this small was
very, uh, this, this network was very small so we are
diving into the network each and every parameter, each and every neuron and seeing
what is the output which is coming from which neuron, so that we are able to
figure out that because the gradient is becoming so high, let me take
the learning rate very small. Okay?
But these things you will not be able to visualize one, you will, once you
will go to the even deeper network. Okay? You will not be...
Uh, although you can always print, but then it is very difficult to
visualizes, we- we- visualize it for the deeper networks
and when you will be using the, uh, um, uh, you can say that
the built-in functions, classes, which is available in the
PyTorch or any, or any other library.
In such cases, what we have, what we do, learning rate,
we kind, uh, we kind of don't change much. Okay?
And we majorly focus on, okay, how these weights are changing and how
the loss are changing because loss is the one which you can actually
track and you will be tracking in order to know whether your network is
tr- being trained or not. Okay. Internal details, I mean,
after certain, uh, time in the sense that once we'll go to the little
deeper network, it is very difficult to track those things and
change, uh, all the, whatever we want to change.
Yeah. Okay?
Yeah. Sure, sir. Thank you, sir.
Yes.
Any other query from anyone?
Um, sir, good morning.
Um, the weights are, uh, I mean, after back propagation, the weights are
reducing, correct? Uh, so can we see any, uh, gradient
descent problem?
Gradient descent problem in the sense...
Oh, no, it's a gradient descent algorithm.
Gradient descent is an algorithm which we are following here. I did not get.
Weights are reducing, I understand what you said.
Most of the cases I see 0.02 and -0.4,
0.5 has changed to 0.4. Yeah. So,
um, yes, in all the cases it has been, it has been observed the
same thing. Correct.
Yes.
But, but, uh, I understood what is, what you're trying to
say, but if you can recall, uh, I...
Next class I'll show that also. That we talked about this, uh,
uh, that, um, curve, right?
Yes.
Convex function where the minima is at
the, at the bottom, right? And you want to reach
there, the global minima part.
Okay.
So it may happen you are in the left side or in the right
side. So if you are right side, then what will happen?
Weight will reduce. If you are in the left
side, then what will happen? Weight will increase.
Because ultimately you have to go.
But I've shown you only one iteration and the, the
initializations and all those are...
Everything is like, um, purposefully taken.
Maybe that thing is not reflected here, but we'll see that part, um, in the
coming classes. Yeah. So sometimes you will see that weight is
increasing also-
Mm-hmm.
... rather than only decreasing. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
Uh, left, uh, right side I didn't get, sir.
Always we-
Ah. ... are going from right to left, so no back propagation?
No, no, no, no, not, not, not that part.
The value of-
Okay, sir. ... these weights. Uh, value of these weights, that is what we were
talking. Here we have seen the, the change
is only the decreasing change that all these parameters we
have updated.
Mm. Yes, sir.
And it... All the parameters are...
Seems to be decreasing by a small amount, right?
Mm-hmm. Yes, sir.
This is what you can see, but then this may not be always the case.
It depends on where you are in that convex curve.
Okay, sir.
Because imagine that X-axis is W, any of this
parameter, and Y-axis is your loss. Okay?
So... And there is a convex, uh, curve here.
So where you are
in that curve, it depends whether the...
In the next, next iteration you try to reduce the loss or increase the...
Ultimately you want to, uh, you want to...
You can say that,
um, loss... I'll just show you that
loss function.
Convex curve.
Yes. So let me just take any figure for that matter.
For example, say this itself.
Okay, this itself. So what is happening here is, this is what I
want to, uh, the, the, the... This is the point where I want to come.
And this is the X-axis, this is the... Y-axis is the loss.
So it may happen that I have a star- I, I am here right now.
In that case, what will happen, I'll, I'll increase the X-axis
value, then only I can come here, right? I can...
I have to go from the left to right. If I have to go from this
point of X to this point of X. Now, if suppose I'm here, then I have to
decrease my X value, then only I can go from this point of X into
this point of X. So the X value will increase or decrease, depends
on where you are in this particular curve. Okay?
Yes.
Because we have seen only one iteration, so it seems to be like it is
decreasing. That means that we were somewhere in the right side of the curve....
but it may not be always the case. That is what I was telling, that sometimes
you may see that you are increasing also some weights value or decreasing.
Both are possible, uh, once we, you understand this, this curve, how
it works for that loss function. Yeah.
Yeah. Sure, sir. Thank you, sir.
Uh, sir? Uh-
Yes.
... in, in the same line of question what Rakeshji asked-
... uh, uh, whether we... Whether the weight will reduce or weight will increase,
that depends on, on which side of the curve we are.
So can we say that the initial assumption of the weights, uh,
uh, playing important role here?
Yeah.
Will that decide? I mean, is there any way to,
uh, judge which will be the better way so that, uh-
Sure. ... very fast we can come to the convergence?
Yes, yes. There are lot of way, lot of experiments have been done
how to initialize the way, initialize these parameters.
Weights, yeah.
If you will not initialize in a way in...
With, with some, some, uh, whatever is the proven techniques, then
it will take more time to converge. It's not like you won...
You will not converge. May take more time to converge, sometimes, uh,
you may not converge also. But, uh, there are some ways.
Maybe next class I'll talk more on those point itself, that how to
start with that, what are those, those ways in which you can initialize your init-
uh, init- uh, iteration number zero parameter.
Right.
Yeah.
Maybe some examples, uh, will give better idea, sir.
If we can take some examples here.
Yes, we will take some example. Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay, I guess this much is fine. Now let, uh,
what we'll do is, I will go to the
Colab.
Fine. So whatever we have learned, I'm going to explain the same
thing. Uh, nothing, nothing different.
So we are going to... Over here. Let me
just keep this
open because I'm going to explain you exactly the same network.
We are going to code exactly the same network and, uh, see that,
okay, where... Are we getting the same value, same thing, what, what is being
listed there or not? And then we'll see the two versions of it.
I'll also introduce today PyTorch Autograd, where
we don't have to hand code the back propagation, uh, part.
Uh, the... That Autograd takes cares of the back propagation
by itself. That, that also I'll show you.
Okay, so to start with, let me just open any Colab
notebook.
I guess that is already available with you, that, uh, Colab notebook, uh, in
the sense that it is available
here. Some of you might have tried
this. You would have practiced it. You will understand it better.
Those who have not practiced, let us see it now, but you need to
practice. To understand that back propagation clarity, you need to
practice
and do some changes, and let's see that what is happening.
That, that will give you the complete clarity.
Once you understand this back propagation, I mean, any kind of neural network, you
will, you will be able to understand, okay, how and what might be happening
inside and all. Okay? All right. So,
uh, uh, let me first connect
this. I will import the Torch.
I'll show you one by one. I... Although the complete code is written there, but
I'll show you one by one so that you will be able to understand it that what, what
is happening and what is the thought process while writing the code.
So I'll import the Tor- Torch because...
Okay, let me import only Torch here.
Matplot- matplotlib I want, but that I'll do later.
So once I have imported the Torch, the first thing what I have to do is I need
to, uh, I need to find what is my input and output
because that is the first thing what we need to...
What we have started here. Look, so
we started with this forward propagation and I
said, okay, this is the dataset and for this dataset we are
going to configure the network. So in the dataset I have four
rows, three columns. First co- two columns refers to my input
and s- third column is referring to my output.
So let me just
create these tensors first of all. So I will create X.
X is going to be my input and I'll use Torch.
And from the Torch, I'll, I'll create the tensors. Okay?
I'll create the tensor. Now, uh, the tensor wha- what I
want to create is the two dimensional tensor. Why?
Because here you see that it's like, uh, uh, I have four
rows and three columns, so I'll create two dimensional
tensors. So
in fact, I will keep IQ and CGPA in X and
LPA in the
other tensors to ma- to, uh, to make it my input and output
clearly. So I'll create two dimensional, uh,
tensors. So this represent for the one dimension, I'll use one
more, okay? And then I'll start using the comma.
So comma. So here, uh, I have the first value as
88. I'll write @80 as 80 and
8. Okay? And, uh, what, what I will do is
I'll simply write point, uh, uh,
y, because th- these values I don't want, uh,
it to be only, uh, what is that? Uh, integer.
It may be, uh, be, uh... Or else, uh, these are just an input, you can
keep it like that also. It doesn't matter. When I'll take...
I'll, I'll initialize the weight, that time I'll keep it i- in the float, float
type. Okay, so then 60, 60
and 9. This is the second data point and I
have, uh, 75, 127. So
third one is
75 and fourth one
is, uh,
127. 127. And
that's all. That's all.I will
run this. I can show you that what has come in X.
So this is my, this is my tensor. Uh,
two-dimensional tensor, which is X. Okay, done.
Now, I'll also create the Y. Uh, Y is
equal to
torch.tensor. Torch.tensor and
then,
uh, here also it is going to be two dimension, but I will have only one,
one value. So two dimension means I'll have the how many rows I want and
how many columns I want, okay?
So that's why two dimension. Uh, 3, 4, 8, 11 is the value
so I will start initializing at 3, then
comma, the next, then
3, 4, then 8, 11. 8
and 11. Okay, that's all. Now I can print
what is Y. Uh, takes one positional argument but four
were given. Okay, wh- what is that? 1, 1.
Okay, here I missed one.
Because I have to create two-dimensional tensor.
Okay, so now it looks, uh, first and second column is for the input and third
column of my data set is for the output, okay?
That I have clearly, clearly created.
Now, once I have these, uh, uh, things created, next
thing if you see that, I need to configure this network where I h-
I, I need to have three inputs, which I have already have.
One hidden layer, one output layer, activation.
This we'll do... We'll, we'll see later.
But before that (clears throat) in this particular network, I need to create these
connections with these weights, uh, weights and, and biases, right?
Because that is what going to be connected with these neurons.
So let me initialize these weights and biases in the same way how we have
initialized here. So I'll also take the same values what we have
considered here. So values Y also I'll not change much.
So this is what I'm going to do right now.
So what I'll do is, I'll write in initialize.
Initialize
parameters.
Okay. And, uh, I'll start with this.
Say the W1_1 then W1_2. So all these things I have to do, so let me start
with W1_1. Okay, and I'll use
torch.tensor.
Okay? Torch.tensor because the value is known to me.
I'll not use rand and value... Or r- rand and,
uh, function at the... which will randomly initialize the
value between zero and one. Uh, minus 1 and plu-
plus 1. So here, I have fixed value, 0.02, which I'm
initializing here. One thing, uh, uh,
which, which is important but, okay, that is not important
here. I can show you in the next, next, uh...
when I'll show the next version of it. Okay.
This is my W1_1 and similarly I'll initialize my W1_2
and, uh, it will be equal to
torch.tensor. Torch.tensor and this will be
0.50.
Similarly, I have other value also so I'll just copy now. Okay.
No need to write everything because I just have to change the value.
W1_1, W1_2 then I'll have
W2_1 then W2_2
and this is 0.- 04 and this was
zero-
-0.30. -0.30.
Right? And then, uh, next layer, I have V1,
V2, uh, s- and then B1, B2, B3. So I have
V1. I'll just copy. So this is
V1.
And this is V2. And these two are 1.2 and
0.8.
1.2 and 0.8.
And then I have B1, B2 and B3.
Sorry. I just need three so I'll say here
B1, B2,
and, uh, B3. Sorry, B3.
Okay. And these values are, uh, these values are one.
Okay? All these values are one so I'll simply write here one.
One.
And one. And all these are
scalar, okay? All th- all these are scalars. That's all.
Okay? So this is done. So what I did, I have initialized all these
parameters. So this parameter. The only thing, what I have to do is, I just
have to
start building these connections.
That X1, X2 will get connected with H1.
So I will define what is the functionality which is happening here and this, this
net- network I have to build now. Okay.
Before I build the network, few more parameter which I, uh,
want to
initialize is learning rate. Learning rate is,
uh, 1 into 10 to the power of minus 4. If you can recall, so it was...
It can be written as, uh, minus
4. Okay? This is the learning rate which is nothing but 1 into 10 to the power of
minus 4. I want to keep, uh, I want to run
this one for, say, um, uh, I'll, I'll
write epochs. Epochs is equal to 2.
Okay? I'll show you what is this. So this is epochs.
Epochs is equal to 2 and I want to,
uh,
uh, I want to, uh, s- um, keep the loss history for
each of these epochs. So these are the three initialization which I'm
doing, uh, I think...
(whispers) Okay? So this is done. So learning rate,
epochs and loss history, I have, uh,
initialized. Now I have to start with my training
loop. I have to start with my training
loop.
AI and ING training loop. Okay,
and here, I will start the For loop for epoch in the
range of epochs. See, it is giving, so, uh, whatever is the number of
epochs I have defined here, this loop is going to run for those many-...
Times. Okay? Those many times. Fine.
So first of all, what I am doing is, uh,
uh, there is something called
zero, uh, gradients. I'll, I'll talk about that.
Now, what is this? But let me first,
uh, or else what I can do is,
um,
uh,
what I will do is, I will... One more thing I will do here, which
is, uh, which is known as, uh...
Few more things are required.
So first of all, let me create some functions, then I will go to the training
loop. First of all, let me just, uh, decide what are the parameters which I
am going to update in each of these parameters, e-each of these iterations, that
is going to be W_11. Okay? Then it is going to be
W_12, W_21, W_22
then V_1,
V_2, V_3, sorry, V_3, then V_1 and
V_2.
Okay? These are all the parameters which we have to update. All right.
So if you will see... This I will come back.
P-a-r-m, params. So all these are my parameters which I have
initialized with. These are all the value. Fine.
Now, what I want is, when I'll, when I will
go to the, uh, first layer where, where here is I
want one activation functions to be added. Okay?
And that activation function is relu.
So that I need to define, because we are doing everything from the scratch, I need
to define that function. So definition, I'll say relu.
What relu will do, it will take the value X.
X w- would be the Z_1, Z_2. And what then it will
return? It will return, it will return,
uh... I'll say torch dot... There
is something called where. Where parameter. Where?
It will check X, okay? And if X is greater than zero,
if X is greater than zero, then it will return X
itself.
Fine? That is what is the relu function.
Else, it will return
torch,
torch.tensor. Uh, and the
tensor value would be
0.0. I think you can... Uh, you are a- you, you are able to
relate this, that what is, what is, uh, going
on. Square X is greater
than zero. So this, this is right. So you can able to
relate it, that how this relu works? I have written the same thing.
If it is a positive value X, then the output will be X
itself. Otherwise, it will be
zero. Okay? Now, I need to
define one more function called as relu
derivative. Because that is what we are going to...
Relu is for the forward pass, and derivative of the relu we'll use for the
backward pass. So relu
derivative, relu derivative... And again, say that
X is the value which it will receive. X is just a variable name.
What value it is receiving, it depends on that. It will give you the output.
Then it will return. It will return what?
It will return, again, I'll use
torch.where. Uh, so
if, if X is greater than zero, then it will
return
torch.tensor. And this
time, it will return 1.0, because you know that the derivative of the relu, if
X is positive, derivative of that would be one.
If X is negative, in the case of relu, means the value,
then it will be zero. That is how the derivative of the relu works, so I'll
write both the things.
Torch.tensor.
Sir, for this, uh, we don't have predefined functions? Relu?
Uh,
I mean, this is a... Uh, here we are doing everything from the scratch so I am
showing you this one.
Okay. Okay.
Going further, when I'll show you the module in the, in the neural
network, there we don't have to write any of these things.
Okay?
Okay, sir.
S- so say that these two were the functions which we wanted and
now I have done. So now I'll start with my training.
Training loop. So epochs, anyway we have
defined here. Epochs, we have defined here.
So now I'll, can start with this for epoch in the range of epochs,
whatever number of epochs we have done.
And then, uh, something, total
loss I want to calculate, which is, which will be initially zero.
Which will be initially zero. And then we are going to add the loss after every
itera- uh, uh, in every iteration, whatever we are going to get.
So total loss, every time we are going to initialize with a zero.
Whenever we'll start any iteration of the forward pass, total lo- loss for that
iteration will s- initialize with a zero. Okay?
Now, there are something I was talking about gradient.
Gradients, uh, uh, initialization, you can say
that. Uh, initialization, uh, which we have done, I guess.
Yeah. Uh, gradient
initialization, uh, it is not required.
Anyway, we have, uh, anyway, we have...
We are starting with our own initialization, it is not required.
So now, uh, what we'll do is, we'll, we'll,
we'll run one more loop. That loop will be for, for,
for, uh, we can say I in the
range of... Or I in the range of, uh,
uh, in the range. Simply in the range, I'll say.
And then I can write, uh, length
of... Length
X. Okay? So this is what is the range in which I want to
run this for loop.Okay. This is why,
why this? Because the is not required. Sorry.
For I in range, uh, length X, means what is
this X? X is this one. So X0 is this,
X1 is this row, X2 is this row, and X3 is this row.
You see that? X will take one, one, uh, row by row it will take, but I want to
run it for all the, all the row, then this is what I have to put here.
If I want to write on... O-only for first row, which I'll show you,
then I can change it to
X, uh, 0 maybe,
okay? Because X0 is just one, with one...
That means that only one row it will take, which I'll show you because I, I have
shown here only for one row and for only one iteration.
Then I will show the same thing here, but you can repeat it for whatever number of
row it is. Then what I will do is, first I will write X1,
X2 and this I will extract from X of
I, because every row has two inputs.
One is CGPA, one is IQ. So X1 will be my, uh, first input
and X2 will be my second input and I is
representing that row, okay? So that is how, uh, this line is
written. Similarly, I am writing my target value which
is, which is going to be my Yi.
Yi. So XI, Yi I have decided for this, for this
training. So then I'll start with the forward pass.
Say that I will start with the forward, forward pass.
In the forward pass, what we have to do, we have to first calculate the Z1 and Z1
is nothing but W11. Here it is written, W11 X1,
W12 X2 and B1. This is going to be w- be, uh, your
forward pass. Uh, first, first node where first we
calculate the Z1 here. I was talking here.
That means that here, here I first calculate the, uh, Z1 and then I'm
calculating the H1. So let me cal- calculate here the H1.
H1 is equal to
ReLu and, uh, inside the ReLu, I'll pass
Z1, okay? So then this will complete my, uh, this, this
particular node. This particular node, right?
And then I will also do it for Z2. I'll also do it
for Z2 is equal to... See, the,
now it knows what I have to write, so it has given me the solution.
So this is also completed now. H1, H2 is completed, now I have to complete this
Y. Okay, once I'll complete H1, H2, then I have to complete the
Y hat. I have to calculate the Y hat, right?
Y hat I'm calculating by... You see this?
V1 into H1, V2 into H2 plus V3. This is what I have to write, so I'll
write V1 and then into... V1 into
H1 plus, uh,
V2. V2 into H2 and plus
V3. Find this, this will give me the Y hat.
That's all. And here, in this particular, uh, neuron, I'm not using
any, um, a-activation. That is what I had shown you,
uh, uh, earlier also for this particular example, so I'll not use an equation here.
Although you can use it, like you have used in ReLu.
You could have used a sigmoid or whatever it is based on the problem statement, but
I'm not using it here. Then I am... Once I have calculated
the Y hat and now next thing what I have to calculate is
loss. Loss is nothing but target minus, target
minus Y hat. Uh, so this whatever, so this I
will write here target minus Y hat and that I
am doing the square. Square. So there's a
squared error, loss is equal to, um, since, uh, this
assignment operator it is actually. So this is what I'm doing.
That will go and sit in the loss. Once we have the loss
value, then initially we initialize the total loss as zero.
So what I will do is, uh, this, uh, I think
this is... This may not be required because I'm doing only
for, uh, one row. It may not be required.
Otherwise, you can just use this total loss also.
It will not, uh, it will not, uh,
make any change, uh, in, in our, um, in
our... Uh, so total loss,
what, what you can write is plus is equal to.
This mean that total loss is equal to total loss plus.
That is the meaning of this sign, okay?
Either you can write it like that or you can write it...
If you're confused, you can write it as total loss is equal to total
loss,
uh, loss plus loss. Um, whatever
loss value I'm getting. So total loss in- initially it is zero.
It will add this loss value in this one. That's all. Yeah.
That is the meaning of it. I guess loss we have calculated.
Once we have calculated the loss, forward pass is done.
Then it's time to do the backward pass.
Okay, then it's time to do the backward pass.
In the backward pass, uh, backward pass what we have to
do is, uh, first of all, we need to...
What we do, we calculate... Now see, it is giving already the suggestions
and, uh, we can, we can use it. So, uh, we
will calculate
partial derivative of the loss with respect
to, uh, Y hat because that is where we have to start. We have...
We know that one, right? That is where we have to start. So you see this here?
I have started with this itself. Backward propagation has started
with this. The first partial deriva- I'm calculating partial derivative of
loss with respect to Y hat. And, uh, I, I will write it
as,
uh, DL, okay? I'll say DL, um, underscore
DY hat. Okay? That mean partial
derivative of loss. D represent the differentiation
here. The, uh, partial derivative, uh, but this is a partial
derivative. Now loss with respect to Y hat which will be two into
Y hat minus target. Correct? This you know that because
same thing we have learned. Two into Y hat minus target. Target is Y here, okay?
Here I have given the variable name as target.
Now that is okay-Once we have calculated this, then we have to start
calculating the gradient with respect to V1, V2, V3.
That is the first thing, right? And if you can see for V1, it
was, uh, partial derivative loss with respect to Y hat
multiplied by, uh, dot partial derivative Y hat with respect to V1.
And the same thing I have to code here.
So now what I'll write is, uh, uh, partial
derivative of loss with respect to, uh, you can
say, uh, or,
uh, partial derivative, uh, with respect to V1, so
DV1, I'm writing for short, is equal to...
Uh, first I have to write, um, yeah, the same thing,
uh,
same thing what it is showing. So partial derivative of loss with respect to DY
hat because this is what is- the first thing which we have to calculate.
And then partial derivative of Y hat with res- uh, sorry.
Uh, here you see, partial derivative of Y hat with respect to V1 and
partial derivative of Y hat with respect to V1 is H1.
Why? Why? Because, uh, all other components will be zero.
You will be left here only with the H1.
So with respect to V1, it will be H1. With respect to V2, it will be H2.
With respect to V3, it will be 1. I have to write all these three, uh,
equations. So V1, V2, it is written, now I will write with respect
to B3 also. The partial derivative of B3,
uh, yeah, same thing. That's all. Okay.
Uh, you can write into one. If you
don't write also, doesn't matter. So now this completes these three.
This complete these three. These three chain rule what you have written, it will
give all this. Now next layer is now we need to calculate the partial derivative of
W11, W12, B1. Okay. Now for B1,
now, you know that this complete chain rule you have to write.
Loss with respect to Y hat, Y hat with respect to H1, H1 with Z1, Z1
with W11. All these things you have to write and let me
show that for you. Okay, so we'll go ahead and we'll start writing
it. So what we'll do is first we'll calculate, uh,
uh, partial derivative DL, uh, par- partial
derivative of loss with respect to...
We have to calculate with respect to H1, okay? That is what you can see here.
With respect to H1. This we have already, right?
DL divided by D, uh,
DL by DY hat, we already have. Now this is what we
need to calculate. Then we will go to H1, then we'll go to W11.
So this is what we need to write. So DL...
DH1 is equal to, uh, this is what it will
come, is equal to... So with respect to H1, it will be,
uh, DL. First of all you have to start with, with respect to DY
hat. Same thing what it is written here.
And then, uh, DY, uh,
D- DY hat with respect to H1. DY hat with respect to
H1. See this? DY hat with respect to H1 which is coming as V1, which is coming as
V1. And that is what it is showing, it was showing me the suggestion as
V1. That's why it's showing me the suggestion V1.
Same thing I will repeat with for H2, but H2 I will do it later.
H2, I'll do it later. First, let me complete the H1 part.
Sorry. Okay, so now, uh, uh,
once we have done for the H1, then we'll, uh, do it for,
uh, Z1. So I'll say DL,
um, I'll say DL...
Okay, uh, I'll say DH1, DH1 with respect
to r- with respect to, I'm writing as underscore,
DZ1. See this, it has now given me the suggestion.
Um, H1 with respect to Z1, I have to do, which is nothing
but the ReLu partial derivative of Z1.
Same thing what it shown. H1 with respect to Z1.
This is what I'm cal- calculate, which is nothing but the ReLu derivative is shown
here by, uh, dash here, and then Z1.
Same thing it is. Now after that I have to write Z1 with respect to
W11. That's all. So, uh,
that I can write it as DW11. With respect to
W11, it would be, uh, I'll start with, yeah,
DL by DH1, this one,
because this and this. This is, these two we have to multiply,
uh, and we'll get, uh, DDW11. The
DW2- uh, 12. Okay? And now
it is, it is giving me the, uh, suggestions already.
Okay. So... Okay, I could
have, what I can do is DL divided by
DH1 and, uh... One
second. DL divided by DH1, um, uh,
then DH1, uh, I will write it
as this one DH1. These two, these two I
have to multiply, right? So that is what I will write.
I will write DH1,
uh, underscore DZ1, this
one, and then into X1. This is what it will come.
Into
X1. Yeah. And
then I will do for
DW112. Okay?
And now it is giving me the right suggestion.
Now I will do it for DB1, DB1, giving me the right
suggestion. That's all. This, this, uh, this, these three will
actually do these, uh, these calculation.
DL by D- DY hat and, uh, this
and, uh, this last one. These three is done.
Now we will do with respect to H2. With respect to H2, I'll just copy
now, okay? It's already 10:04. So now I think, I think you have
understood. I'll just copy this. I'll just copy this,
okay? Just a second. You must have
opened it somewhere else, or else, or else
here. Okay. Here it
is. Yeah. So... Yes, this
one. Uh, this, this part I have shown you.
Now I just copy this
one.Okay. In fact,
I'll copy this whole just to have any kind
of...
Okay, so same thing. Till here I have shown you al- already and
this is just with respect to H2, these are all the gradient we will calculate
and that's all. So we have three gradient here, three gradient here, and three
gradient here. B1, B2, B3, W11, W12, B1 and
W21, W22, B2. All these things are now done.
Now, once it is done then we need to update the parameter as, as I
had done here. That once we have all the gradient, we need to
calculate this. Uh, we have to s- do this theta minus
theta. Theta is equal to theta minus learning rate into partial
derivative. Now this is what is left and this is what is written here.
So W11 is equal to W1 minus learning rate into
W11. That is written as minus is equal to.
This is how you can write it. So W12, then B1
then W21, 22, B2, V1, V2, V3. Everything is done and
finally, loss whatever it will come, I am going to store at
the history so I will use loss_history which I
have... Put here too. Which I have initialized
somewhere as empty list. Where? Where? Here.
Loss history is empty list so I'll store that one in this.
Okay, Y is not defined. Where is Y? Uh, this
Y... Oh, is it a... Is it,
uh...
Well, Y then... Okay. Tensor takes one position or
two are given where torch where. Okay, here.
There also we have some issue. So X is greater
than, uh, zero.
Brackets is missing, sir.
W- What? What is that?
One dot zero.
Brackets. Brackets.
Oh,
It's extra.
After one dot O. No, no. After one dot O, then brackets should be there, no?
Comma. Before comma. Yes.
Oh, okay. Here? Here?
Yeah.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Correct, correct, correct. Yes.
So I just should run unmatched. What is that? Unmatched? Okay.
There it is. Unmatched. Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
All right. So what is this? W11 output with shape
empty does not match with the broadcast shape one.
What is that W11 is equal to learning rate into
DW11. Same thing we are using here.
Update parameter. Okay.
Output shape, uh, this line it
is.
Okay.
Mm-hmm. W11 (...)
.
Learning rate into DW11. Python
error. (...) shape
does not match the broadcast shape one.
All right. What is this? Okay, I'll just see that what is
this, uh, later. But for now I guess, uh, this is
what we have done. So I'll run this one because this was
running already. I'll see that what with
the... Aha. So this much we have done and then
if you will able, if you will print this loss history, I just want to
show the loss history because I wanted to, uh,
show exactly the same thing what is happening here we can
produce. So here the... I'll change only thing is, I'll do
that... No, I'll do it, okay. I'll again I have to
run, run all. So see
this, the loss is coming as
87.5856. Okay, why
it is coming like that? Let me once again check it.
So this is fine. This is also okay.
Okay. This is also okay. This is...
They are the same weights which we, with which we have initialized our toy
example and here it is okay. Uh,
epoch, I will say one
and then I will try to see what is 87.
Why it is 87? Uh,
is there any reason? Because, uh, loss, once we calculated
it, what, it is supposed to be 54 point something.
That is what we had written
here. The loss is supposed to be
54.1696 and then next loss should be
4.005 because we are taking the same set of values
so it should not change it. That is what I was expecting
and it was like that only but there is some change.
Okay, you can check that. Maybe we are running little o- out of
times. Uh, you can-
I was trying the same thing when you were doing this.
Huh. Like I'm getting around 53 point something.
Oh, then I guess, uh, it is, it is the same thing, but, uh,
I just trying to see what- So you can delete the runtime and
then, uh, restart it and run all. Maybe. Maybe.
Yeah. So what I will do is I
will, uh,
runtime restart the session, I will
do. Okay. Maybe. So I... This is
what happened. It might have stored some initial value of those weights
parameters and may... Oh, sorry, might have initialized with
that.
Uh, this one is done,
and, and this, and this, and this, and
this.
Okay, this is also okay.
Oh, still it is coming. Anyway, we'll see.
We'll see that later sometime that what is going wrong
here. Uh,
so it is coming like that, but I'm not sure why it is coming.
I was expecting something else. Uh,
I, I think when you-
The losses you're adding, total loss, right? Uh, is that final?
And total loss, it will
be (...) summation of (...) .
Uh, this is okay. Why I'll say you that the total loss I'm
initializing with every iteration zero.
Uh, so whatever it's coming from...
It's why I have used this line is because, uh, if, uh,
if... Okay, here, uh, now got it. Why it was coming like that?
Here I have changed, change. Now it will come.
So I'll start again from here.
I'll show you what, what was the
issue.
Oh, second one is 4.5, first one is still not...
Uh, so what, what I was doing is I
am running, uh, this one. So
instead of length I would say X0,
and
let run. No. Okay. So I want to run
only for one, uh, you can say the row, because that
is what we did there. Uh, here, if I want put it,
uh... Or else I'll simply write here, uh,
one. Okay? I'll simply write here one and,
uh, I will turn it everything once
again.
Uh, now you see that it is the same thing what we have got, so
54.1696 and 4.005, the... exactly the same
thing we have got here, okay? So the problem was that in
this line where I have the inner loop,
I want to run only for first row, I don't want to run for...
But when you write length, uh, this is what is written here.
If you want to wrote... Y- run it for entire row then it will go for one by
one. Four rows are there, right? And that's how the loss was also more, because it
was accumulating all the four rows loss,
okay? Uh, which you can do, which is a right practice also which you...
But then I wanted to show here only for one row.
So now it is working, okay? So you see that?
This is, this is coming exactly same thing what we were... desired.
So this will also, this will also change now.
So initially it is 54 point, then it is four point something and then this is the
new all, new parameters, okay? Loss history has two
loss, 54 and four. Now quickly, I'll take another two, three
minutes maybe because I wanted to show this today itself.
So there is a, uh, module called
AutoGrad in PyTorch, okay? Uh,
only f- little change I'll show you what is going to happen.
See input is going to be same, X and Y I'm not changing, so it is
going to be the same, X and Y. The weight
initialization, whatever we have done, it is going, it is the same.
Learning rate is same, epoch is same, okay?
Loss history I have initialized same.
Training loop is also same. Training loop is also same.
This, this is the same thing that I just want to have one
row. So first represent the row, how many row you want, and how many column
you want. That is how it is written as.
So X1, X2 and, uh, um, that's, that is what we have designed.
Then Z1, H1, Z2, H2, Y had the way we have calculated.
Everything is same, okay? This is the forward pass what we are doing,
okay? Then we have calculated the loss then, um, we have stored the
loss in the loss history. Now when it comes to the back propagation, this is the
only line, this is the only line of change what you will see in
this code and in the previous code.
So, see in the previous case when we had to calculate the gradient,
these were all the lines of code which we have written.
We have actually hand coded every gradient one by one, written every line
equations one by one. AutoGrad,
AutoGrad is something which, uh, gives you the flexibility
to, uh, do e- everything automatically.
So what it will do, you can simply call loss, whatever loss you're
getting and you can call this function called back, backward,
okay? You can, uh, uh, call this function
backward and it will do
all these things what we have done here. Everything.
Start with the partial derivative loss with respect to Y hat, then Y hat with
respect to the, say V1, V2, V3 then H1, H2 and Z1,
Z2 then d- all these parameters. So instead of writing all these
things, you can write only one function called dot backward,
nothing else, okay? And then, uh, the way we were, uh,
updating all these parameter, W11, W12, B1, nine
parameter, same thing is being done here, W11, W12, all these nine
parameter we are updating. This line is not required
here. I mean, I will just delete, no problem.
Uh, or else let me keep just to show you how the loss is changing.
You can actually check that also. Let it be.
So, uh, m- so you see that the change which I want to show
is that, uh, in the PyTorch you
have, you have the AutoGrad, uh, mm- module
and, uh, you need not to import anything for that one.
Whatever loss you're getting, it is by default.
If you will call back, backward, it will calculate the gradient
for all the parameters what you want,
okay? So that is how it is going to be and now let
me run this also. Now see that, what has happened, loss has come as
54.1696, exactly same loss which I wanted after
first iteration. After first iteration, okay?
Now after this iteration, uh,
means it's not first iteration also, it is just a forward loss and
then we will just, uh, uh, we have just, uh,
calculated the backward. Backward when I say, all the nine gradients are calculated
by this one line code and all the parameters you are updating here,
okay? Then, uh, here is the updated parameter, all
this parameter exactly same you will find.
Loss history when you will see, you will see, you will find it exactly the same.
54.1695 and 4.005 in the earlier
code also it was in the same way. That means that the AutoGrad is
working exactly in the same way. Uh, the way we have coded
everything here hand coded, gradient and all, because it's, uh...
Ultimately it's a gradient calculation we have, we have affixed, uh, equation
for that one, so the chain rule, chain rule.
The chain rule, it has implemented for us.
So it has made our life so easier just by writing this one
line.Okay. And this is what I wanted
to, um, uh, I, I wanted to
explain that what is this autograd?
So this is going to be very helpful for us in the coming classes where we'll
have the deeper networks and we have to do the gradient calculation.
We'll not write because we may have thousands of parameters.
We can't calculate, means, uh, calculation will be done but we
can't be writing the thousand lines for those thousand gradients
equations, okay? So then we can simply use this backward and
then it will do the same job for us, okay?
So you can see that there is no change in terms of the loss and no change in terms
of the, uh, you can say that the, uh, co-
um, everything is same. In fact, the plot and all, everything is same.
Fine? So yeah, this is what I wanted to explain and hopefully
now, this, this hands-on has given you more understanding that how
these forward pass and backward pass is working.
And now, slowly, we will dive into little more, uh, deeper networks
and slowly, mo- slowly I'll show you maybe in the next class if I get
a time that how to use more modules from the
PyTorch. Like, okay, the backward pass was looking
here difficult so I have used
the function from the PyTorch. But what about the forward pass?
Here, although these are the equations in the forward pass, these are the equation,
right? Z1, Z- Z1, H1, Z2, H2, and output Y
hat. Going further, when you have 10, uh, 10 layers of network, even
the forward pass, writing these equations would be very difficult.
And hence, we'll use some other, some other modules again from the
PyTorch to make the forward pass also almost, like, uh,
automated. So you just pass the input, it will do all the lay- layers
of the, uh, calculations and give you, okay, what is the overall loss
finally. Okay? One more thing which is going to hurdle
us, that this, this manual parameter update. This one.
Here, still I'm doing the update of the parameters manually
but going further when you will have thousands of weights, parameters or millions
or billions of parameter model, like large language model, we can't be
writing this one line by line every time. So in...
Again, in the, uh, PyTorch, we have a module which will support all these
weight update, uh, parameters automatically.
So that also, I'll introduce but I didn't want to introduce everything at once
to show you that, yes, it is the same thing, whether you write by hand coded or you
write, use those modules, this is what it is doing in the backend
so that you will be able to understand.
So going further, you don't have to write it everything but you should be knowing
what is going in the backend. Okay? That is the intention.
Okay, so, uh, yeah, this is what I had to present.
So now, what I, uh... It's 10:20, I have
another 10 minutes, I guess. Okay.
So what I will do is, I will, uh, uh, do it for
little more number of epochs. Here, it was only for two epochs.
Maybe I'll run it for 10 epochs and, and,
uh, maybe I can change this one, right?
I can go from, uh, all, all rows,
I, I can use. I can use all the row, uh,
and for X1, X2, right? And, uh,
????? So here, here also then I have
to use. Here, it is specifically Y so if I use
Y hat whether it will work out. So it will not work.
So I have to use here also Y.
Okay. This you could have do, you could have done here also.
No,
uh, same code it is, so doesn't matter.
Instead of using range one, if I'll use the length
X, it will use all the row, one by one.
All the row, one by one. All the four rows, one by one. Okay?
And then it will calculate that. One more thing, the last
thing, uh, what I want to show here
is, uh, this particular part. See that, uh, initially,
this, uh, uh, gradients are initialized
with 0, 0. Someone said that, "Sir, you restart that, uh, uh,
runtime and then it will work," and so.
Uh, it may not... It might, uh... At that time it was not working
but this part is very important, you know?
This part is very important. What it is doing is, it
is making your gradients value zero.
So wherever it is DW11, DW21, DV2, that means that
it's, uh, what, uh, the gradient we have calculated with respect to that
parameters. So whenever you are starting the next
iteration, you make sure that you
make all the gradient value zero. Because last time, we have calculated all these
gradients, right? Now, if you go ahead in the next
iteration, the gradient will again start from this
value. This value. Which why we don't want, okay?
Then you will see unusual, um, uh, unusual
outputs and you will not be able to understand.
So make sure that you always initialize your gradient to
zeros whenever you will start the next iteration.
This is, this is what you have to do it.
Here also I have done the same thing with this for loop.
So for all the parameters, for all the parameters.
So what I'm saying is,
the parameter's row gradient is not none.
Obviously, it will not be none
because you have updated it in the last pa- last, uh, iteration.
Then calling that param.gradient or
grad.zero_, _ means in place.
In place means, means, uh,
W11.grad.zero, means W11 value will be set to
zero. Whatever is the W1 value or W12 or W22
value, all these parameters value will be set to zero.
So, uh, uh, o- or their gradient value set to zero.
So grad is a function which actually is setting it to
zero. Actually, it is setting grad to zero.
One more thing finally, uh, whenever you have to use this, uh...
Here in this particular code when I was showing, I had wh-
while initializing the parameters, you see that I have initialized the tensors
like that. Sorry, uh, this is...... uh, tensors like that, right?
Input is anyway same. But when I was initializing the parameter, initialize the
tensors like that. If you see the difference, if you see the difference here
as compared to what has happened here,
there is one change you will see and this change is very important to
observe. Whenever I have initialized W1,1,
torch.tensors 0.02, here it was, that's
all, 0.02, but now I'm writing, comma, required
grad is equal to true. Required grad is equal to
true. So what has, er, wha- what, what does it mean?
It means that I'm trying to, trying to say that
I, I want the gradient for this partical-
particular parameters. I want the gradient for this because whenever I'll call
backward, what exactly happen, it is going to create one
computational graph. Computational graph.
Computational graph is something that how the process has
taken a shape in the sense that, uh, let me just,
uh, here.
So I was explaining about the PyTorch autograd.
I'll u- I'll upload these slides, whatever I have explained that,
uh, this is the computational graph, that from X1,
I, uh, ca- came to Z1 where
and, uh, where I did say that the, uh, the,
uh... It is not exactly the computational graph but then sh- it's a
representation of that. X1 to Z1, how did we come?
Maybe we have done the multiplication.
So multiplication is the operation in between.
From Z1 to H1, how did we come? ReLu was in
between. From H1 to Y hat, how did we come?
So then again, multiplication was in between.
So this is a, this is a computational graph, the kind of com- computational.
Not exactly, but kind of computational graph which auto- uh, which that
backward function creates, which that backward function crea-
ba- backward function follows, not creates, follows.
So backward function is going to follow that, okay, Y hat, how did we calculate the
Y hat? So we actually used H1 into V1, H2 into
V2, so there was a, uh, addition operation or say that
multiplication operation, whatever it is, doesn't matter.
But that operation, it has to backtrack, then on, then only it is going to
calculate the gradient for that particular parameter correctly,
okay? So, uh, what I mean to say
once again, that whenever you will use this autograd, you
make sure that for all those parameter which you want to update,
makes it, uh, or use it for the gradient calculation, you use this
parameter, requires grad is equal to true. By default, it is false.
By default, it is false. No need to write this grad false, but by default,
it is false. Otherwise, uh, uh, uh, you have to
write it as true if you want it, okay?
Likewise, I have written for all the parameter, requires grad is equal to true.
So if I show you what is this W1,1, see
this? So it is saying that requires grad is equal to true, but
when I will, uh, uh, show the
X, X, uh, say that's zero or X
simply, um, X is not there. Sorry.
Yeah, capital X. So here it is not saying that requires grad because it was set to
false, right? So it was no- it is not showing that it requires grad, but here it is
showing that one. That is first change.
One more thing I wanted to show
that, um, suppose I want to print, uh,
Z1, okay? I want to print Z1.
Uh, see, what is writing here is Z1 value it is giving, no doubt.
Z1 value it is giving, say that, one, two, three, four values, it is
giving. But this is what I want you to focus
on, add_backward, because I have set
the, I have set, uh, the, um,
it is true, so Z1 is being... This Z1 got calculated using
W1,1. So Z1, how did you calculate it?
By you, by... In the backward, you have done some, um, addition
operation. Obviously we have done some oper- and that is why it is written
add_backward, okay? So you can also see
all those things, all, all these, uh, whatever it is.
So if I will say, uh, the
W1,1, this, this is coming, like, because see, if you see this particular equation,
what you are doing? You are doing the multiplication, that is okay.
But at last, you are doing the addition between these three, W1,1 X1,
W1,2 X2 and V1, all these three, you are adding.
So it was writing as, uh, it was writing as add_backward.
If I want to see what is H1, you see that what is there?
H1 value is just giving, that is okay, but then it is in ReLuBackward.
In the backward, what operation had happened? ReLu.
So this is being tracked. Every parameter is being tracked
that, okay, what are the operations you are doing on which parameter?
If you will put this requires grad is equal to true.
And that's why
when you call this backward operation, it is able to calculate the
gradient with respect to all the operations which has happened in between,
okay?
So yes, this is what I wanted to say.
This is what I wanted to explain a little bit maybe, uh,
yeah. So
you, you just do the practice. See that, okay, uh, what is the,
uh, what is happening, uh, and, uh, I guess, uh,
then you will be able to understand it better. Okay?
Okay, I'll stop here for your questions.
You can ask me if you have any query, then we'll, we'll close this
class.
Yeah, any query?
Thank you. It was very intensive. Thank you very much.
I mean, a- as in it was very laborious and you took us through everything.
Thank you very much, sir. Sir, both the collabs are shared, right?
No, first one is shared. This autograd is not shared. I'll share it today.
Oh, okay, sir. Thank you, sir.
Yeah, yeah. Yes, please.
Sir, um,
the, the ReLu activation function is applied on the,
um, the output after the weights are applied on the input,
right? So if there are multiple layers-At each
layer, this ReLu is applied, right?
The same ReLu activation function, whatever we choose.
Correct. Correct. Correct. It's not always ReLu, you can change it to any other
activation function for that matter.
But yes, whatever you apply, uh, in that particular
layer, suppose you have 10 neurons.
For each neuron, that activation, activation function gets applied
and that is being calculated. But-
Um-
... layer by layer, you can decide what activation function you want to keep. Yeah.
So we, we choose one activation function for the whole network?
Uh, no, that is also not... That's what I'm telling this network itself I showed
you, right? In one layer I used ReLu, but in the output layer, I did not
use it. So it depends on layer. Activation function is for that layer
and for all those neurons-
Oh, okay. ... in that layer. Next, uh, layer you can use some
other. So for the whole network, you may use multiple activation functions also.
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
Um, sir. Good morning, sir. Uh, so maybe in the next class, I have a small request,
sir. As here we are given the data is a two dimensional data.
At least for next class we can just show me one example how we take an image and
then we take the data and do this back propagation.
That we'll do going little forward. We'll do it for sure.
Okay. That is also there, but, uh, don't want to complicate
it. Uh, so I will show you those things slowly and
because-
Okay, sir.
... CNN when we'll start using right, that time I have planned to use the image
data. RNN, LSTM-
Okay. ... when we'll learn that time, we'll use the text data and we'll do
that first.
Those things will definitely do that.
Okay, sir.
Because here we are mostly trying to understand everything from the scratch.
Taking those complicated data would, uh, it is
not possible for me to make the PPTs based on that.
I can make the PPT only for this try examples and all. Yeah. That's the reason.
Yes, yes.
Yeah.
All right. S- is there anything else you want to
ask?
Sir? It is clear now, sir. Okay,
sir.
All right then. Then we'll meet on next day, Monday, and we'll
continue. Thank you.
Sure, sir. Thank you, sir.
Thank you,
sir. Thank you, sir.
Thank you. Thank you, sir.
Okay. Thank you, sir.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Thank you,
sir.